qui déteste la période de noël moi
j'adore comment elle compte en effet pas
parce qu'avec tous les cadeaux que
j'avais affaire à lui il ya deux jours
noirs dans l'année noël et la saint
valentin c'est la catastrophe
il sait que quand ça arrive aux frères
il met en place totale non mais c'est
vrai je sais pas ça mais ça me fout le
cafard mme bah oui mais je vais faire
quoi d'ailleurs pour noël vous à las
vegas trois noms se font le jour de l'an
alors ça va on se voit on se fait
plaisir avec quelques affamés
[Rires]
non mais alors et progresser nos jeunes
et on est en famille - voilà et tout le
monde bien la maison faute à toute la
famille les ex fabien il ya la famille
actuels 1 vous faites un noël avec
chaque femme ou bien je serai avec mes
enfants
d'accord elle différente maman vous
aimez la période de noël vous aviez jeff
et jean-marc j'adore embauché shatter
qui vous n'aimez pas aussi je déteste
parce que ça va être deux ans donc non
je ne fais plus quand elle était jusqu'à
ce qu'on appelle le noël déficitaire je
me rends compte que les cadeaux que
j'offre sont des valeurs supérieurs à
ceux que je reçois
16 et non on est bien d'accord donc
maintenant ça va c'est pour y aller et
se foutant déficit enfin il fait le
calcul des cadeaux qui reçoit et de ceux
ci la fin mais bon tu connais de leurs
mots il aura beaucoup beaucoup de temps
pour faire tous ces calculs calais le
pire cadeau de noël que vous ayez reçu
un oui j'ai reçu le touriste a de quoi
le temps reste à achat d'or ce jeu c'est
un chien ouais on lui donne à manger la
pâte à modeler puis fait concrète et ben
apparemment on a donné la même pâte à
modeler jean michel maire veut toujours
quitter voilà je peux vous dire qu'il
n'est pas bien bien serré et j'adore ce
jeu moi
le touriste vous et quoi de pire cadeau
que vous ayez vous vous c'est quoi un
silex
quand vous avez quand j'avais 18 ans que
j'étais plutôt en creux
ma belle mère m'en faire une gaine n'ont
déjà pas déjà j'en ai jamais eu un oui
je suis tonique les autres et donc ça
m'a vexé que j'ai eu c'est un dauphin
monstrueux qui avait des yeux rouges et
qui était bleue marine
je sais que pire cadeau qu'on ait fait à
bernard montiel c'est l'auto bronzant et
vénère de ouf il était à stains noël
mais l'horreur oui maman n'est pas loin
à 17 ans m'avait offert une crème
régénérante une crème de corps et
brûlage que j'avais mis donc le soir
pour appeler un coup d'éclat comment il
faut retirer tout ça est en fait j'ai
fait une allergie à ouallam avait brûlé
tout le contour des yeux rien j'avais un
destin exceptionnel
non mais vraiment lui leur destin c à 10
c
ce mec vous et vous moi j'avais un bébé
diarrhée d'accord un bébé diarrhée ouais
quoi ça sert un bébé qui avait la
diarrhée 1,3 d'accord vous aimez manger
fils
[Musique]
merci la régie ya déjà pas cadeau pourri
à quelqu'un qui n'aimait pas du tout ça
c'est faux je remarque je crois pas non
mais par contre j'ai des idées nathan
williams et l'offrir eu à noël je
choisis des cadeaux oui des canaux aussi
ajouté des cadeaux ouais quoi réagir
mais aussi derrière gameiro ok il ya un
an la bascule j'ai offert à quelqu'un il
tournait autour de ma copine il était
stupide pour lui prouver qu'il était
stupide un petit âne qui bascule est
comme ça j'avais scier le truc
dès qu'il est si c'est cassé la gueule
et des gens étaient méchants taristas
quel âge sa 44 à la foule
18 28 19 ah ouais il était déjà tard ito
qui s'est déjà engagé pendant un repas
de noël
jean rabat a dit je suis allée ouais
c'est agace thalys et une famille d'où
il ya passé sa part au pugilat et très
doux il n'ya pas ses dettes il divorce
il ya mon beau-père de l'époque qui a
renversé tout le plat sur la nappe et ma
mère à l'ats péter un câble non elle a
pété un câble c'est vrai quoi le et ça
c'est annick ans d'histoire à laval a
pété un câble non mais sinon rien les
avions sont à féliciter
[Rires]
il ya déjà très chaud le soir de noël
non on nettoie noël mais en fait j'avais
fait un reportage et en mère noël sur le
char du père noël à disneyland
non et le père noël ils étaient mais
chaud comme la braise quoi il n'a pas
arrêté comme on pouvait pas nous
entendre
vous voyez seulement fallait qu'on fasse
très bon et il me disait des trucs
[Rires]
alors je te l'avion au moment de ce
carrefour car noël à dieu ça c'était
vous mentez à donner à croire que je
suis plus sexy quand je suis en mère
noël faisait toujours c'est donc à la
faille pechoux boillon mais dans la
période de noël qui a déjà fait choux la
vérité ballu bon c'est la bo qui nous
touche pas à la nuit entre les boules et
le sapin la sortie sa bûche alors ça
coquinous du quai en famille pour les
autres on s'en fout et puis plus ces
histoires de guide de déficit il ya deux
ans - 416 connaissait depuis noël
mais du coup comme je suis seul il ya un
site pour personne sensible alors que je
le dis un appel à noël on baise banane
ouais les gars qui s'appelle à noël on
écoute du sud vous lui demander de
raconter
or daniel méchant parce que dans ce cas
la moelle osseuse au réveillon on sent
qu'il manque à gagner par matthieu
delormeau n'a pas attendu le réveillon
oui alors vas-y alors carrément des
récits n'existe pas c'est là alors
d'aucuns site s'appelle à noël on fait
l'amour c'est tout bête c'est un site
pour les gays tout ça c'est que souvent
il ya beaucoup de genres morin soit à
paris ou quoi le soir de noël qui sont
seuls devant la télé tout ça et les
boîtes de nuit le soir de noël son tour
soit fermées soit vide
ouais bon ben voila tu étais gaieté
sensible tu t'ennuies un petit peu du
coup tu vas dessus ce sont des gens
c'est que ce soir là et sont libres pour
faire la fête
donc à nous à lombez qui va être c'est
les gens qui sont pas enfin décider gay
qui sont pas en famille mes livres il
faut ramener quand même sa boule et sa
guirlande qu'on tape à la porte de salut
dans ses pouvoirs il faut montrer patte
blanche
ap le sos détresse amitié gate quartet
hall on se retrouve
mais tu peux faire des actions
caritatives allez denain qui n'ont pas
de gps et alors et alors aidons à ben
alors à vous les l'histoire bah oui
alors j'ai tombé sur un très jolie
métisse qui était aussi qu'ils étaient
qu'était-ce banon mais voilà et donc
c'est un peu noël donc les petits mots
timo site est rigolo c'est moche pas si
me regarde d'ailleurs je ne sais pas ce
qu'il fait à noël et on n'aime pas ça
noël extrêmement agréable et beau
écouter mais ça me fait vraiment plaisir
vous est alors moi le chant de noël le
jour de l'an 90 98 et 2000 de la ba la
balle a bien commencé l'année doc a été
vain la trois fois le jour de l'an le 31
non pour moi on le sait la tâche est
aussi fois dans ma vie du monde
la hyène coupe du monde qui est passé tu
vas canada trois fois c'est ouf ça
incroyable c'est ma nuit franchement 1
c'est vrai oui je dis il en faut une et
les autres mais van persie
vous avoir dérangé la personne il m'a
arrêté avec quoi et avec moi vous donner
un peu arrêté avec moi arrêter voix
est-ce qu'il faut arrêter le bégaiement
des voix la pression mais les jours
d'huile oui mon coeur je vous posais une
question alors je suis abonnée aux bleus
ont la poubelle mais là les français
cela porte à la pause à tout à l'heure à
20h02 si vous voulez mais vous êtes en
ttc la note était hanouna sparadrap oui
j'ai eu et j'ai eu un petit problème
oui je me suis blessé voilà pause m'a
dit je me suis rasé qui sera dans le
coup j'ai pas envie d'en parler on s'est
mal passé
il
[Applaudissements]
je me suis fait griffer ah ah non mais
c'est quoi
oui monsieur glee fait ce cas il faut
graver un choc qui s'annonce alors déjà
c'est dans la nuque
bah oui enfin parlé tout à l'heure c'est
rien de très folichon vous le dites mais
je vous dirai ça sent le centre d'un
club qui bafoue cadeau de noël à ses
collègues de travail
tiens tiens déjà prévu des cadeaux vous
vous êtes déjà plus des cadeaux j'ai
prévu de faire des cadeaux j'ai pas
encore prévu le cadeau ce que moi je
vais dans les magasins je regarde et
j'achète bas comme tout le monde nous a
déjà fait à quelques unes d'entre nous
tes cadeaux dans sur les lignes à
géraldine et moi nous a offert des
mitaines devrait jamais en fait
confiance au bac 5 pour les familles
parce que servir enfin bon avec un votre
courrier dans la semaine qu'elle serait
d'accord pour se déguiser en père ou une
mère noël pour faire un petit câlin à
moi qui regardais jamais confiant -
direct vous l'avez qui a déjà fait ce
qui s'est déjà navigué christine kelly
shalit je suis sûr connaître économie
christine kelly au csh pour vous dire
allez les gars se déguisent alors ouais
je suis sûr qu'elle s'est déjà déguisé
plus fallait bien mais tu ne joues pas
quatre jours en guadeloupe avec elle je
peux vous dire voilà choper en
guadeloupe j'étais super comment je sais
pas moi j'étais au csa je crois bah oui
soit quihouët et non j'étais hyper carré
mais par contre quand je suis pas à long
terme quand je ne suis pas au csa et
quand c'est à noël et quand je suis avec
mon chéri quoi ça peut partir en tout
cas voici il peut se passer des choses
quoi c'est vrai vous êtes déjà déguisé
en quoi en mère noël non
[Applaudissements]
de ce va écouter sur la tête de ma mère
quand elle est descendue de la cheminée
mon frère elle est descendue de la
cheminée je l'attendais comme ça c'est
un truc de ouf ça sert et et avec qui
mais je sais maintenant j'étais jeune
mon mari non non votre mari oui mais
avec mon bain
il ya de belles tenues quand même un
pour les mères noël ah ouais non mais
c'est vrai de très bien est acheté ça ou
parce qu'il ya des mères noël c'est
clair je me rappelle pas parce que je
conçois date dans la section témoin oui
comme un nom à la série qui s'est déjà
déguisé belgique beinheim s'est déguisé
en tajine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous connais castaldi aux moines ont
dit la vérité cette meuf qui s'est
déguisée pour toi non non je vous jure
que non
terry gou je vous dirais que je veux
vraiment la vérité on a fait ça rend la
one for christmas is you non non la
carène mariah carey hyper drôle parce
qu'il est tout un peu comme ça quand
même tir au thillot vous vous êtes à
riom mario courir j'avais des petits
fûts comme ça un peu rôti comme ça un
peu près et bienvenue à tous et un outil
baptisé rigoles ou quoi c'est vrai et
vous bien sûr en infirmière salaces avec
le petit des baisses bien fait tuer
[Rires]
vers vous vous étiez qu'un mec à
joliette a rigolé c'est quoi une
infirmière salah c'est un petit peu ou
vela la blouse verte est reversé à ses
actionnaires qu'ils proposent j'étais
avec quelqu'un qui était un peu âgé donc
y voit on affirmé mais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé donc vous êtes arrivé bah
ouais comme quelqu'un comme nom moi
j'étais avec mon mari trompé se marier
instagram est donc plus un peu ouverte
avec le petit cdc stéthoscope et la
mi-journée ausculté vous l'avez ausculté
de partout j'étais jeune
toujours jeune alors et donc ça s'est
bien terminé
moi j'aimais blajan l'air las bons
souvenirs souvenirs mais vraiment
derrière elle a cédé ghislain morillion
dinosaures non c'était une fois j'ai été
en bunny encore baigné bernard meunier
un petit nid de bonis a way et moi ça me
gonfle et déguisements il mon mari c'est
tellement énervée à vouloir me détruire
au bout d'un an il a tout arraché et on
s'est dit que définitivement un
déguisement c'était pas bon nous fallait
s'en sort c'est là que les veut arriver
que chaque fois tu sais qu'un gars comme
moi ce que tu vas tomber génie c'est sûr
et certain
et vous non jamais koné
elle sonné je connais gillot si ça ne se
déguise pas en direct
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]